plus de cent mille clients
d'hydro-québec sont toujours privés
d'électricité depuis le passage d'une
violente tempête samedi plus de cent
cinquante mille clients en ontario au
plus fort de la tempête plus d'un
million de clients étaient privés
d'électricité on rapporte 10 décès 9 en
ontario et au québec l'est du pays était
touché par ce qu'on appelle des red
chaud une tempête de vent qui se
déplacent rapidement et qui couvrent une
large superficie les rafales de vent ont
dépassé les 140 km heure à certains
endroits et on fait des dommages majeurs
les changements climatiques rendront de
moins en moins exceptionnelle des
phénomènes météo comme ce qu'on a vécu
d'ailleurs en fin de semaine est-ce
qu'on investit assez dans l'adaptation
au changement climatique avec nous ce
soir julie et bourque qui est associé de
recherche à l'institut climatiques du
canada bonsoir monsieur bourque
bonsoir d'abord est-ce qu'on a tort
d'associer un événement comme ces grands
vents de la fin de semaine au
dérèglement du climat aux changements
climatiques
oui et non en fait je m'explique le sait
en terme de ce conseiller des
changements climatiques par rapport à
l'exploitation des précipitations par
exemple qui augmente l'humidité qui dans
l'air on sait qu'il risque les périodes
ces années on serait plus longue ce
genre d'événement de pour arriver et
puis quel et risque aussi d'être plus
intense et plus et l'a identifié
spécifiquement comparé à d'autres comme
des températures par exemple
le premier coup calculable des
catastrophes ce sont bien sûr les
assurances mais on va le voir dans le
graphique les biens endommagés
les résidences les routes les voitures
est ce que c'est la partie visible et on
le voit bien dans le graphique au fil
des années il ya de plus en plus de
coups qui sont associées aux sinistres
catastrophiques assuré et la ligne rouge
qui monte et donc qui montre clairement
qu'il ya de plus en plus de coups est ce
que c'est la partie visible de l'iceberg
selon vous
oui effectivement c'est exactement ça
c'est d'ailleurs le concept qu'on
utilisait pour mohan terrible de projet
à l'institut de son coût des changements
climatiques ce qu'on voit là c'est
vraiment la pointe de masse bleus on
utilise aussi par exemple des données
des accords d'être financière en cas de
catastrophe que le provincial et fédéral
vient de financer des infrastructures
publiques sont pas assurées par exemple
puis c'est très clair qu'à traverser les
rayons on voit clairement le cas les
événements météorologiques
ils sont plus fréquents un pick up le
culturellement plus cher ce convoi ont
su ensuite en dessous de la surface
convoi - par exemple c'est
l'interruption des activités économiques
des rapports sur les chaînes
d'approvisionnement des impacts en
cascade au monde ajoute exauce par
exemple qui sont plus celles à prévoir
puis sont certainement plus du
coelacanthe fils est ce qu'on est
capable d'évaluer les dommages la fin de
semaine
c'est encore tôt je pense mériter comme
vous l'avez montré je pense que les les
assurances on nous montrait on le donne
une idée de l'ampleur hydro-québec ou si
leur sortie coup suivant le cours pour
leurs équipes qui sortent en ce moment
vers
s'adapter au changement climatique
s'adapter à ce type de catastrophe ça
veut dire quoi et ça coûte combien
ça coûte combien chose certaine c'est
que eux ne rien faire ça coûte beaucoup
plus cher que de s'adapter ça c'est
clair c'est un dvd constat qui ressort
d'une recherche on a fait dans cette
série si tu commences sur les
infrastructures
comment s'adapter pour les systèmes
électriques par exemple ça veut dire de
n'ajouter l'entretien autour des lignes
par rapport à la végétation par exemple
ça peut être comme ça ça peut être dans
certains cas d'enfouir les lignes des
réseaux électriques où ils seraient plus
à risque mais c'est aussi rendre le
réseau plus flexible donc par exemple
des sources de production qui serait
décentralisée je pense aux au toit
solaire par exemple pour les grandes
surfaces des systèmes de stockage puis
tout notamment dans nos hôpitaux puis
d'autres services comme ça que c'est con
dont on a besoin dans ce genre
d'événement mais quand vous parlez par
exemple d'enfouir
des lignes électriques là il ya plein de
gens encore ce soir qui sont privées de
courant ça coûterait combien de rendre
notre réseau de distribution électrique
comme ça moins vulnérables
ça coûterait ça coûterait quand même
cher dans le sens où enfouir les lignes
c'est certainement une des solutions est
vraiment à la connaissance mais pour
donner un exemple de
chiffres de sorties cette étude
c'est dans un contexte où les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre continuerait
comme elles le font ce moment puis on
s'adapte pas au changement climatique on
a des réseaux d'ici 2050 donc en mise en
forme on a juste pour un indicateur on
peut s'attendre à des 'coups de métier
puis de remplacement on parle même pas
ici des vendeuses vers rio tout ça c'est
vraiment notre assiette normal ça
pourrait s'élever à 650 millions par an
les voir jusqu'à un million si deux
médecins au québec simplement qu au
québec seulement 2 par la grandeur du
réseau alors que si on est en mesure de
diminuer notre professeur puis d'adapter
nos réseaux
on parle de sources de réduction des
coûts de l'ordre de 40 % d'ici 2050
jusqu'à 85% des salons si on réussit le
vert mais est ce qu'on le fait est ce
qu'on le fait suffisamment est ce qu'on
fait cette planification en ce moment on
le fait pas suffisamment encore
évidemment ça dépend des ça dépend des
régions ça dépend des sinistres aussi
par exemple au niveau des réseaux
électriques je sais qu'il ya de grandes
réflexions qui sont faites de vous dire
au québec puis deux autres dans le
service public au canada donc ils ont
dit que d' avance
les inondations par exemple on est très
loin des formations qu'on a besoin pour
savoir où sont les risques
dont quelques chinois fabriquent et les
inondations pour une troisième fois en
six ans gatineau demande à ses citoyens
de se préparer d'ailleurs à des
inondations
est-ce que ça demeure sera la principale
menace pour les secteurs densément
peuplées
oui c'est la première cause ce soit en
terme d'assurance ou deux coup c'est
l'inondation a au québec et au canada
lucky qui coûte le plus cher qui
arrivent le plus souvent évidemment pas
de parler c'est dommage qu'ils font puis
l'emploi de dimanche les inondations
vont faire son niveau côtiers ou à
l'intérieur des terres donc
effectivement toujours du numéro 1 puis
je rappelle encore une fois que si on
manque clairement de l'information les
dates les pardons les cartes de plaine
inondable le canada des années 70-80
notamment 18 et puis prennent
certainement pour complet des
changements climatiques qui commençait
sa vraie-fausse avait affecté les
plaines inondables jeudi 1 bourque de
l'institut climatiques du canada merci
merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit